for years now we have been told that
president donald trump is the biggest
liar in american politics so the new
york times says he's told
tens of thousands of lies and as
examples of his lies they always point
to
some slight exaggeration about crowd
sizes or something like that
in fact there is a a much more prolific
liar
in american politics and unfortunately
one who's about to play a much more
prominent role
that would be kamala harris which we
will get
right into first though i want to
mention this video is sponsored by ring
ring is the name to trust in home
security and smart home technology
more from them later but first these are
people forget
the people forget they memory hold them
they don't get played on the news they
don't end up
in the news articles or the wikipedia
page these are my
favorite transparent lies from kamala
harris first one
kamala harris is on the breakfast club
radio show describing how much she
enjoyed
smoking pot in college listening to
tupac
and snoop dogg have you ever smoked i
have
okay and i inhaled i didn't i did it
[Laughter]
it was a long time ago but yeah i know
you have to go there you have to go
i just broke loose i mean whether in
college
so you see i like stuff like that that's
a really good dance
it was
[Music]
oh my goodness oh yeah definitely snoop
uh-huh
uh tupac for sure
so this is hard to watch actually and
and hard to listen to because of that
cackle that makes hillary clinton sound
like she's pavarotti or something you
know i don't know
i never thought i would miss hillary's
cackle but kamalas is worse
you can tell that this is a lie well i'm
sorry the reason you can tell it's a lie
is because tupac and snoop had not
released albums bef when kamala harris
was in college
so that's just transparently a lie but
even if you didn't know that fact
you would tell it's a lie because
the radio hosts are guiding her answers
and she doesn't know they go
have you ever smoked pot uh hmm what's
the politically smart thing for me to
say here
frankly i wouldn't be surprised if
kamala harris never smoked pot once
even in her life but she's thinking she
goes ah what's the more politically okay
yeah i smoked pot yeah yeah when was
that uh
uh was it in college yeah yeah college
college
yeah okay was it a blunt or a joint uh
uh what i don't even know what those
things are uh i guess a joint
blunt would have been the funnier answer
but joint okay yeah yeah and what are
you listening to
tupac and snoop okay obviously that
isn't true
it's bizarre how our standards have
flipped in the old days the
the politically favorable answer would
be i never smoked pot i
only listened to bach i only listened to
mozart or something
but now because the standards are
flipped it actually makes her seem
much cooler and much more politically
mainstream if she has smoked pot and
listened to rap
but frankly maybe she hasn't done either
of those things
in her life on this topic of rap
i know that she didn't listen to tupac
in college and i know she didn't listen
to tupac
after college because kamala harris
clearly doesn't know who tupac is best
rapper alive
tupac he's not you say he lives on
not a lot i know i keep doing that
listen west coast girls think tupac
lives on i'm with you i'm with you so
tupac
keep going i keep doing that
i keep doing that because i don't know
who tupac
is and some staffer told me he was a
rapper or something who's the greatest
rapper alive
uh tupac how about biggie is that does
that work
dude please elvis is he a rapper i don't
know please elect me
please like me i'm so cool i i actually
the nearest thing to honesty i've seen
from kamala harris is where she says
yeah i keep doing that you keep doing
that because you have no idea
even the lie that you're trying to
contrive and this
usually is playing on sort of identity
politics she certainly does that with
her childhood
memories of kwanzaa which we'll get to
in one second
so much happens at our front doors that
is one thing that certainly has not
changed these days at my house for
instance
getting more grocery deliveries getting
more packages
getting more visits from in-laws and you
want to make sure
that you can tell which is which if it's
the pizza delivery guy you run you open
the door if it's
maybe other people you stay perfectly
still and just wait for those people to
pass
this is a wonderful way to do it ring
when we moved into tennessee the first
thing sweet lilisa says she says
i can't wait to install ring just
tremendous stuff also makes a great
housewarming gift
i've given this away to friends of mine
as a housewarming gift and
it makes me know that they're safe and
you know it's a cool present for them
best part for me it's not that expensive
so i get credit for a great gift i don't
need to spend a lot of money
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kid at ring.com
knowles know w-l-e-s comes with rings
video doorbell 3 and chime pro
the perfect way to upgrade your front
door and start your ring experience go
to ring
dot com slash knoll scanner wles
ring.com slash knowles so kamala harris
was
uh looking back uh on her wonderful
childhood while she was
making a pandering identity politics
video about the socialist contrived
holiday
of kwanzaa and here are her memories
happy holidays everyone
i wanted to take a moment to send my
warmest wishes to everyone
celebrating kwanzaa like so many other
holidays
we will be celebrating kwanzaa a little
differently this season in our home
we'll be doing it over zoom you know my
sister and i
we grew up celebrating kwanzaa every
year
our family would in our extended family
we would gather around across multiple
generations
and we tell stories the kids would sit
on the carpet and the elders would sit
in chairs and
and we would like the candles and of
course afterwards have a beautiful meal
and of course there was always the
discussion of the seven principles
and my favorite i have to tell you was
always the one about self-determination
kujicalia and you know essentially it's
about
you know it's about be be and do
be the person you want to be and do the
things
you want to do and do the things that
need to be done
it's about not letting anyone write our
future for us
but instead going out and writing it for
ourselves it's about be
and dew and one of the great kwanza
luminaries frank sinatra he said dooby
dooby doo
and b doo doo dop bop boo
no that didn't happen i don't think that
happened uh when kamala harris was a
baby kwanzaa did not exist for the first
two years of her life
then when it was invented by a criminal
actually who tortured women and went to
prison for that a guy named melania
karenga
it was only celebrated or even
recognized in black power
circles and like the black power
movement the black panthers something
tells me that kamala harris was not
running in those circles with her indian
mother and her jamaican father jamaican
father who has called his daughter a
liar
before so i just i don't really buy it
also
kamala harris submitted photos to the
washington post during the campaign
of uh her and her sister celebrating
these holidays at winter time you know
what they were celebrating not kwanzaa
they were celebrating
christmas an even more ridiculous lie
that kamala harris concocted
just came out uh you know in early
january that lie
is one that she'd told in this in
october of 2020 and
even earlier that when she was a little
girl she was at a rally
she was protesting she fell out and she
said she wants freedom
i i witness this as i write about in the
book you know from my stroller's eye
view and
um there's a funny family story about
how so my mother's marching
with the extended family i talk about
like aunt mary and uncle freddie in the
book and
um she would tell the story about
houston they're marching
and this is back when strollers didn't
really have arm rest and seat belts
so they're marching away and you know
shouting and
and all of that and then she'd say so
then she would look down at me and
calmly what do you want what do you want
and i looked back up and i said freedom
oh the cackle yes she told that same
story to l magazine
turns out she lifted it from a martin
luther king interview with playboy in
1965 where martin luther king
describes being at a rally and a girl
was in her stroller you know and sort of
looks down he says what do you want and
she says
freedom doesn't even didn't even change
the sort of silly pronunciation
of of the word and you know i'm sure
kamala harris if you read her that
interview with mlk she would say and
that little girl was me
even though i would have been one year
old at the time and i don't think so
don't buy it not for a second
freedom she is
an ardent liar a cynic in the sense that
she doesn't really care about the truth
at all but as a result she's she's much
more willing to just
lie as though she's breathing she was
actually called out for this on 60
minutes of all places on a left-wing
newscast
and she didn't have much of an answer
for it you're very different
in the policies that you've supported in
the past you're considered the most
liberal united states senator
i somebody said that and it actually was
mike pence on the debate stage
but yeah well actually the nonpartisan
gov
track has rated you as the most liberal
senator
you supported the green new deal you
supported medicare for all
you've supported legalizing marijuana
joe biden doesn't support those things
so are you going to bring the policies
those progressive policies that you
supported as senator
into a biden administration what i will
do and i promise you this
and this is what joe wants me to do this
was part of our deal
i will always share with him my lived
experience as it relates to any issue
that we confront and i promised joe that
i will give him that perspective and
always be honest with him
and is that a socialist or progressive
perspective no
no it is the perspective of of a woman
who grew up a a black child in america
who was also a prosecutor who also has a
mother who arrived here at the age of 19
from
india who also you know likes hip-hop
what do you want to know i want to know
about your political views
well mike pence just said that no
actually it was you just have the most
left-wing voting record
but i'm a black child and my mother's an
immigrant and
what do you
[Laughter]
okay very uncomfortable to watch that
and then the the most
egregious probably or the most blatant
kamala harris was called out by a
left-wing comedian stephen colbert
who said hey you know you called joe
biden a racist at that debate
uh what happened why are you working for
him now
how do you go from being such a
passionate opponent
on such bedrock principles for you
and and now you guys seem to be pals
it was a debate
[Laughter]
not everybody landed punches like you
did though
it was a debate so you don't mean it
it was a debate that the whole reason
literally it was
a debate it was called a debate
and colbert is looking he's like how can
this be your answer because governor
said wait so you're telling me you were
lying during the debate
yeah it was a debate and when i debate
and when i speak in public i lie
isn't that what everybody else does no
kamala but i guess that's what we
have to look forward to goodness
gracious me